[Aplausos]
gracias
bueno yo no sé si esté por aquí bajo
extraordinaria charla majo miren
en 1998 subí el aconcagua un macizo de 7
mil 35 metros sobre el nivel del mar el
techo de américa el punto más alto del
continente una montaña que se sube más o
menos en 10 días
tal vez cargando 45 50 kilos
pero la historia que les vengo a contar
hoy no empieza aquí empieza ese mismo
año muchos meses atrás en una montaña
más pequeña él te la pone una montaña
qué fácil para entonces había subido
como unas 150 veces esta montaña se
encuentra en la autopista puebla-méxico
pasando el río frío 4000 81 metros sobre
el nivel del mar
yo estaba muy contento recuerdo en
aquella ocasión porque estaba estrenando
mi brújula en aquel entonces pues bueno
tenía sus brújulas así la sacabas y tal
pero recuerdo que había comprado una que
era de mano de aquí tipo reloj tenía
barómetro altímetro padrísimo así la
saqué hay al siguiente día nos fuimos a
subir el te la pone y ahí vamos como
veníamos de bajada a la montaña se
cierra es decir se nubla todo empieza a
llover y perdemos todo sentido todo
punto de referencia y lo primero que
dice el guía es carlos donde está el
norte entonces hago mi super super
brújula
el norte está para allá el guía se
orienta y dice es por acá esa montaña no
les miento la bajábamos en nuestros
mejores tiempos el descenso nos llevaba
como 30 tal vez 40 minutos corriendo
después de una hora que seguíamos
caminando sin encontrar el camino que
nos iba a llevar a donde habíamos dejado
los coches el día vuelve a preguntar
dónde está el norte carlos dónde está el
norte sobre su saco otra vez mi super
brújula el norte está ya entonces el día
vuelve a calibrar bueno vámonos para
ahora ya y seguimos caminando dos horas
tres horas para la cuarta hora que haga
rato me decía dónde está el norte y
seguíamos apuntando tal taltal
comenzamos a divisar este cierto conato
de civilización y decimos ya llegamos
cuando preguntamos dónde estábamos
porque no ubica vamos nosotros tenemos
que llegar a esta población que se llama
llano grande estábamos en una población
que se llama se llama coatepec
la geolocalización que ven ahí es el té
laponia no grandes donde estaban los
coches y la flechita
donde salimos
era claro que se me había olvidado hacer
algo muy importante después de sacar mi
brújula y era calibrar la
había que hacer un proceso muy simple
que no me va a quitar ni un minuto para
que la brújula supiera bueno como como
objeto pudiera determinar y localizar el
verdadero norte
esta misma brújula ya después calibrada
nos salvaría la vida a mí ya mi equipo
en 1998 cuando subimos el aconcagua y no
encontrábamos el campamento base de
bajada
llevo un poco más de 20 años dedicándome
a la educación
me encanta ver en los ojos de muchachos
de preparatoria de universidad pero
también en organizaciones
y esta actitud de querer ser mejor cada
día y cuando me preguntan cuál podría
ser de repente la mejor pieza de consejo
que yo pudiera darles y yo me remoto a
esta reflexión y les digo encuentra tu
verdadero norte
porque no puedo imaginar lo trágico que
sería la vida de una persona con su
brújula personal y profesional mal
calibrada iván yo lo viví en carne
propia esté a punto de perderme pero yo
hoy te puedo preguntar cuál es tu
verdadero norte un gran pensador de hace
mucho tiempo de nombre íñigo de la
provincia de loyola decía no hay peor
tragedia para la persona que no saber
por qué se vive porque se sufre y por
qué se pasa aquí esa que han venido a
este mundo qué es lo que te guía cuál es
tu verdadero norte y para definir tu
verdadero norte se necesita mucho valor
la gente de repente se acerca y me
pregunta oye carlos y cuál es tu momento
más difícil en una montaña yo les digo
cuál crees tú que sea he escuchado de
todo bueno cuando estás subiendo cuando
estás llegando a la cumbre cuando estás
arriba de 6000 metros y ya no hay
suficiente oxígeno cuando vas bajando
aquella vez que llegaste a este álbum
cansan en korea y al mismo tiempo que yo
iba llegando iban bajando a la primera
muerte de la temporada
no ninguno de ellos mi momento más
difícil y de verdad se los digo es
cuando 23 de la mañana salgo de la carpa
de la casa de campaña un frío no sé
menos 14 grados tal vez sales con todas
las capas de chamarras que te pones te
pones tus botas dobles te pones la
mochila las sientes el peso 50 kilos y
sabes que los vamos a cargar por los
próximos 15 días respira si llenas tus
pulmones de aire tan frío que te
recuerda que estás vivo y el momento más
difícil
es el primer paso
la decisión todo el peso emocional que
lleva este primer paso
te va a mantener al siguiente y al
siguiente y al siguiente he subido
muchas montañas y he visto a muchos
montañistas que no se animan a dar el
primer paso porque dar el primer paso
podría significar dar el que sigue y
luego el que sigue las personas maduras
toman decisiones las personas inmaduras
se free que and se apanique and y no se
mueven las personas maduras generan
momentum toman control de su vida y
deciden y si la decisión fue mala bueno
se aprende y se repite pero no se quedan
quietos toman decisiones porque en este
andar podría ser que se te diga como
aquella obra magnífica literaria de
tolkien en el que el gran maestro
gandalf se dirige al pequeño hobbit y le
dice cuando el hobbit estaba desesperado
y porque a mí me pasa todo yo ya no
quiero decidir esto yo lo que tenía esta
cochinada de aire anillo me está yendo
del carambas este los orcos nos quieren
matar
y entonces el maestro sereno susto no
puedes decidir que de repente pase esto
esto y lo otro pero lo que sí puedes
decidir es qué hacer con el tiempo que
se te ha dado y ese es un gran regalo
que tenemos todos todos los días
segunda gran lección somos las
decisiones que tomamos tomamos el
control de nuestra vida y todo lo que
pasa es el resultado de las decisiones
que tomamos
en este ascenso al aconcagua uno podría
pensar que la posición más importante es
la de hasta adelante y con justa razón
es la persona que va decidiendo a dónde
ir por qué camino conviene cuál no
ahí vamos esta es una foto de aquel
entonces no se ve muy bien hasta
adelante va el día inmediatamente atrás
va la que hoy es mi esposa mi chica de
la montaña ahí va ello y va
inmediatamente atrás de ella y ahí vamos
caminando a punto de llegar a la cumbre
confiados en que el guía sabía lo que
tenía que hacer en aquel momento una
falta de oxígeno en el día hace que
pierda la cabeza y se siente y diga yo
ya no subo y dos mese carlos te toca a
ti y yo nunca había ido al aconcagua no
tus le dije a mariana mi chica de la
montaña dije pues vamos y entonces
asumió el control y me puse yo enfrente
y empezar a caminar digo ya llegando le
pegando a los siete mil metros sobre el
nivel del mar
falta de oxígeno un cansancio terrible
tener que levantar la pierna porque la
nieve está terrible desde alto dos tres
pasos y no podía más
[Música]
y cuando ya no podía más mi chica que
venía acá atrás hizo un gesto que tengo
15 años de casado nunca voy a olvidar
ahorita estarme con nuevo con su
cabecita me pegó mismas y en la espalda
pude dar otro paso más ya no pude más y
ella tomó un segundo gesto
me rebasó chin chin chin chin chin y se
puso adelante y dio dos pasos más y no
pudo más y entendí que me tocaba mi chin
chin y otro paso más y me tuve que pasar
yo hasta adelante
entendí que igual de importante es el
que va hasta adelante
la guía hacia dónde vamos cómo es el
liderazgo pero también importante es el
que va en medio escuchando palpando el
sentir del equipo de la acordada se
trata de que todos lleguen pero también
importante es el que va hasta atrás tal
vez más importante la retaguardia el que
se asegura que todo el equipo llegue a
la cumbre en 1997 un gran académico
robert green leaf propuso una gran un
gran estilo innovador de liderazgo le
llamó el liderazgo servidor cuya
propuesta hoy suena por demás disruptiva
hoy el líder es el que más está adelante
el pro activo y que sabe por dónde tenía
que ir venga síganme robert green live
dijo no necesariamente
el verdadero estilo de liderazgo es un
estilo de liderazgo de servicio
ahí está el neozelandés edmund hillary
con su sherpa tenzing norgay
las primeras personas que llegaron como
lung a la gran diosa de las montañas
ustedes tal vez la conozcan como el
everest la montaña más alta del mundo en
un hillary no hubiera podido llegar a la
cumbre sin su sherpa tenzing norgay que
le servía que le ayudaba y tenzing norte
y no hubiera podido llegar a la cumbre
del everest sin su guía es muy hillary
el día de hoy los tiempos actuales
requieren un nuevo estilo de liderazgo
un un liderazgo que opte por por no
pensar en quien el yo yo yo sino en el
otro en una idea diferente que se atreva
a descifrar los códigos sociales y este
ha habido de responder de servir de dar
en lugar de recibir en lugar de él canta
llano batalla
conviértete en el líder que todos
esperamos que sea y tal vez solo tal vez
podamos darle la vuelta a la tortilla de
tanta cosa hay tanta barbaridad que nos
pasa como sociedad y por eso doy clases
porque le apuesto a que complete un
veintitantos años dando clases y sé que
por lo menos con que sea uno y solo uno
de los estudiantes que que les he dado
algún alguna clase lo que sea asuma este
papel de líder y cambie y haga algo por
esta sociedad puedo morir satisfecho a
entonces sí puedo decir bueno vaya por
lo menos contribuir un poquito la
montaña piense en la cumbre no se
alcanza rápido no es algo que lo logra
ya vamos de volada y llegamos y
sanseacabó
llegar a la cumbre es una sucesión de
pequeñas victorias pequeños esfuerzos
que se celebran este paso es en sí una
victoria y este otro es en sí mismo una
victoria es esto que mencionaba es
generar momentum a cuente en su primera
de sus clases de física primera ley de
newton ley de la inercia todo cuerpo
permanece en reposo y seguirá en reposo
toda su vida a no ser que llegue una
fuerza externa y modifique su
comportamiento y ese toque se llama
momentum y yo creo sí que a eso estamos
llamados a generar momentum a estar en
acción se nos va a poner de esta manera
soy ingeniero pero está fácil de
entender la parte de arriba es qué pasa
si todos los días por 365 días hacemos
lo mismo hacemos uno lo mismo 365 días
del año pues saben que busquen va el
resultado va a ser el mismo
pero si cada día haces un pequeñito para
ver lo que esto significa
una centésima de esfuerzo de dedicación
de compromiso de ser bueno con los demás
de ser empático con tu entorno una
milésima
cada día hace la diferencia 337 hace la
diferencia
la cuarta gran lección es que ese
sentido común los cuerpos en reposo
permanecen en reposo en otras palabras
los que no hacen nada no van a hacer
nada
para cambiar para ser mejor en lo que
sea que quiera hacer mejor en tu familia
en tu vida en tu empresa en la
universidad con tus amigos
hay que generar momentum
el que está en reposo va a estar en
reposo toda su vida
ley fundamental de física
recuerdo un ascenso al citlaltépetl el
techo de mexico el pico de orizaba
habíamos llegado a nosotros desde la
cara sur
y nos encontramos en la cumbre con unos
montañistas que me han subido de la cara
norte y nos encontramos en la montaña
algo pasa en las cumbres de las montañas
que como que te hermanas con todos los
que la suben
este estábamos ahí repartimos convivimos
yo le di la mitad de mi sándwich a otro
el otro medio rancheritos que sean muy
ricos a más de 5.700 metros sobre el
nivel del mar
compartimos el gatorade lo que sea uy
qué buenos tipos dijimos en el equipo si
son muy buenas personas bueno adiós nos
tenemos que ir muy bien
tomamos nuestras cosas yo iba a bajar
por la cara sur ellos iban a bajar por
la cara norte antes de nosotros comenzar
a bajar sea que esta foto tal vez no no
sé si lo vean muy bien aquí bueno se ve
ahí pero hay unos puntitos son seis
puntitos son los seis amigos que conocí
ese bien la montaña yo bajé
llegamos a ciudad serdán que es la
locación que está ahí abajo del pico de
orizaba para enterarnos que estaban
subiendo las labores de rescate porque
seis montañistas habían muerto por la
cara norte
no puedo ni recuerdo me vuelvo a poner
la piel chinita y yo había saludado a
ellos yo les había dado la mitad de mi
sándwich y así de primero es la vida uno
a veces se llena la boca diciendo que
nadie sabe ni el día ni la hora y puede
ser
y de hecho así lo es
y si es así pues más valiera que cada
día de manera significativa tratará de
trascender de verdaderamente cambiarle
la vida a alguien porque creo
personalmente que es la única forma que
tenemos para trascender hacer para
alguien la vida mejor y estas son las
cinco piezas de consejo que yo pudiera
de alguna manera clasificar de lo más
importante que he aprendido a más de
cinco mil siete mil metros sobre el
nivel del mar pero los dejo con un
adicional
la montaña es como la vida y en la vida
lo que sea no la gana ni el más fuerte y
el más preparado ni el más sabio ni el
mas fantoche por así decirlo no este
dominar un par de temas a saber hablar
en público y acá de tal
la batalla de la vida la que se libra
acá adentro cada uno sabe cómo lidiar
con todo lo que tiene acá adentro esa
batalla se gana sólo aquel que está
seguro de poder hacerlo solo aquel que
lo sabe y que decide que toma la
decisión y decide caminar lo y decide
hacerlo ustedes la gran mayoría veo que
son como millennials y ustedes tal vez
no se acuerden de la primera película de
karate kid y a lo mejor piensan que el
karate kid' es jackie chan con jaden
smith no no hay mucho atrás este en ur y
yuki pat morita como el señor miyagi y
rush máximo como daniel sanz y en una
parte de la película cuando va a empezar
a entrenar daniel sanz lo para el señor
miyagi listo
tarada daniel
si lo vas a hacer hazlo si no lo vas a
hacer no lo hagas si lo vas a intentar
tarde o temprano como a ciruela pasa y
lo mismo te digo hoy a lo largo de todo
el día has tenido piezas de conocimiento
y sabiduría extraordinarias sales del
montón a 100 personas aquí contrató el
resto que en la universidad en puebla
por el número que quieras
muy probablemente algo te ha sonado en
el corazón decir yo puedo ser mejor yo
puedo cambiar las cosas si lo vas a
hacer hazlo si no lo vas a hacer no lo
hagas permanece en reposo ya sabes lo
que pasa pues y lo vas a intentar
tarde o temprano pues como a ciruela
pasan muchas gracias